hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
this is a no calculator question
the value of the logarithm of 3 to the
base of 2
is which of the following options
between one and one-third and one and
one-half
between one and one-half and one and
two-thirds
between one and two-thirds and two
or between two and three
this is adapted from an oxford
admissions test
pause the video if you'd like to give it
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so before i get to the solution i'll
mention this problem is an example of
calculating an upper and lower bound
this is a very useful skill in
mathematics particularly if you take a
university course like real analysis
so how can we solve this problem
let's write x is equal to the log of 3
to the base of 2.
by the rules of logarithms this means 2
to the power of x is equal to 3.
now let's raise both sides to the power
of 3.
notice that 3 cubed is equal to 27 and
27 is less than 32 which is equal to 2
to the power of 5.
this means that 2 raised to the power of
x raised to the power of 3 will be less
than 32 which is equal to 2 to the power
5.
consequently 2 raised to the power of 3x
is less than 2 to the power 5 which then
means 3x is less than 5.
we then divide both sides by three and
get x is less than five over three which
is equal to one and two thirds
this is an upper bound on x
now we'll do the same sort of exercise
to get a lower bound
we start out the same way but now we'll
raise both sides to the power of two
three squared is then equal to nine
nine is greater than eight and eight is
equal to two raised to the power of
three
this means 2 raised to the power of x
raised to the power of 2 is greater than
2 raised to the power of 3 which then
means 2 raised to the power of 2x is
greater than 2 to the power of 3 so then
2x is greater than 3.
we then divide both sides by two
and so x is greater than three halves
which is equal to one and one-half
and this is a lower bound
so now we're going to put these two
inequalities together and we get that x
is between one and one half and one and
two thirds and that's answer choice b
incredible we solved this all without
using a calculator
thanks for watching and for making mind
your decisions one of the best channels
on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]